aires e benvenuti il nuovissimo video
oggi parliamo di coinquilini che cos'è
un coinquilino praticamente quando
all'università o quando si lavora e si
condivide una casa quindi ci sono più
persone che vivono sotto lo stesso tetto
ogni persona è un coinquilino oggi
voglio raccontarvi qualche esperienza
che io ho avuto con i vari coinquilini
che ho cambiato ho frequentato
l'università
quindi cosa è successo mi sono
trasferita da torino a milano e ha
dovuto ovviamente trovare una
sistemazione a milano
la maggior parte degli universitari non
ha le possibilità visto comunque i
genitori pagano anche l'università è
tutto di affittare una casa da soli
quindi il più delle volte succede che si
va in una casa e si dividerà casa con
altre persone o si affitta la stanza
oppure si affitta il letto quindi magari
una camera doppia
ogni ragazza ogni ragazzo ha un letto ma
passiamo a me in questo video appunto vi
voglio raccontare qualche episodio
divertente
ne ho viste di ogni perché nei tre anni
da universitaria diciamo ho cambiato
varie sistemazioni e appunto vari
conquilini partiamo dall'inizio quindi
il primo anno io appunto arrivavo da
torino non conoscevo assolutamente
milano e io mia mamma ci siamo trovate
nel giro di pochissimo tempo perché ho
deciso di scrivere università quasi
quando stavano già iniziano le lezioni
quindi era proprio una situazione di
trova la casa subito quindi primo anno
mi trasferisco da torino a milano e devo
assolutamente cercare casa nel minor
tempo possibile perché ero iscritto a un
pelino in ritardo quindi stavano per
iniziare le lezioni e dovevo
assolutamente trovare una sistemazione
cosa succede praticamente in quasi tutte
le università ho sentito velocità c'è
una bacheca con i vari annunci di case o
camere in affitto io ero lì davanti che
leggevo gli annunci a un certo punto
sento la voce di un ragazzo dietro e che
mi fa stai cercando casa
beh direi di sì non li sto guardando per
passare il tempo e niente questo ragazzo
aveva trovato una casa in affitto
semmai servivano due conquilini perché
appunto c'erano tre stanze e quindi ho
visto che ero veramente lei stava li
dovevo assolutamente trovare casa in
fretta gli e tuara vengo justo
pomeriggio se mi piace la fermo io mia
mamma andiamo a vedere la casa e non mi
dimenticherò mai praticamente era ben
chiara tipo stile anni 60 entro nella
cura che doveva essere la mia camera
c'era un letto singolo solo con la rete
quindi molto accogliente e una lampadina
che cadeva dal soffitto qui senza
lampadario mia mamma guarda la proprietà
dice signora comunque un lampadario
dell'it e poteva anche comprarlo cioè
voglio dire è bene che sono studenti
però era veramente troppo spartana e
quindi io ero tipo così però come vi ho
detto ero in ritardo con i tempi
assolutamento varie casa e insomma
questo ragazzo che mi aveva affermato in
bacheca mi sembrava simpatico e quindi
retto per andare con sconosciuti ormai
bene o male ho fatto amicizia con questo
mi trasferisco qui allora oltre a me a
lui c'era un altro ragazzo questo
ragazzo non parlava con nessuno perché
non avesse il dono della parola poco
perché non parlava non comunicato e
quindi era come se fossimo solo io e
l'altro ragazzo tutti coloro che hanno
avuto modo insomma di vivere con altre
persone quindi hanno avuto dei
conquilini sanno quanto sia spesso
difficile riuscire a convivere ea
rispettare le abitudini degli altri
perché perché se tu cucini e lasci
piatti sporchi senza lavarli e io
ovviamente arrivo dopo di te la lezione
affamata e oltre avete da cucina devo
anche lavare i tuoi piatti per poi
rilevare i miei non funziona così tipo
ecco questo ragazzo che appunto non
parlava tanto anzi proprio forse detto
c'è una volta e poi non l'ho più sentito
parlare magari era timido per carità
però viviamo nella stessa casa non dico
di non diventare migliori amici però un
minimo di conversazione un minimo anche
soprattutto di rispetto verso gli altri
lavati piatti cioè perché devo fare io
niente quindi già iniziava a mare la
convivenza ma la cosa peggiore che io
ovviamente dove vado a vivere con due
maschi e due maschi universitari il
bagno cioè avete presente o filini cioè
devo mettere il cartello sito off limits
perché non si poteva entrare non si
poteva entrare in questo bagno dove
questi ragazzi è sporca vale non
pulivano non entra e lo specifico però
insomma i pubblici degli eccessi non li
voglio trovare scuse è chiusa parentesi
incazzatevi quindi immaginate la gioia
di maria sarà un persona super precisa
super pulite arrivo li vedo la
situazione è veramente mi veniva voglia
di andare nelle scendere al bar e andare
in bagno al bar
io praticamente nel giro di due tre mesi
è diventata la donna di servizio della
causa quindi io l'amavo io pooling se
non l'avevo io vivo la casa la casa
rimaneva sporca ovviamente figurati se
due passi cosa succede che il ragazzo
uno dei due quello che simpatico
mi veniva dietro ci provava e io tipolo
rifiutavo nel senso va bene come amico
patetico franzone niente quasi a fine
anno era più o meno marzo aprile
non so perché forse avevo bisogno di un
po di affetto niente ci siamo ritrovati
può guardare un film insieme in boh non
so cosa è successo perché non lo so però
se hai fatto che siamo fidanzati è
durata due mesi comunque breve va intesa
e niente
come la posso definirmi per fare era un
bel ragazzo
in realtà prima non mi sembra un bel
ragazzo poi è andato un po in palestra
quindi vietato più fisicato come piace a
me
e niente
il cervello per ora di volo sino quindi
un saluto tra l'altro sera questo video
è andata così e sei un bel 6 tuttora un
bel ragazzo altre doti gli avrò la
fortuna e niente questo è il primo anno
dopodiché ci siamo ovviamente lasciati
durante l'estate e lui si è trasferito
da un'altra parola data parte del mondo
e niente non ci ha sofferto più di tanto
ecco secondo anno dopo un'esperienza di
convivenza con gli uomini deciso
ovviamente di tagliare fuori gli uomini
dalla mia casa e quindi sono andato in
un'altra casa con delle ragazze queste
ragazze erano all'università con me
quindi le conoscevo già diciamo che
erano abbastanza libertine in che senso
libertine nel senso che più volte mi
sono ritrovata gente nel letto che io
non volevo nel mio letto gente che
magari loro recuperavano in discoteca e
bisognava al mattino con degli
sconosciuti nel letto cioè cose poco da
film scioccata e scioccata ovviamente mi
incazzavo come la iena perché voglio
dire
mettilo nel tuo cioè non è che presa non
c'è più spazio nel tuo scuse lasciamo
stare
una volta voglio insisterò mai avevo il
giorno dopo un esame difficilissimo non
mi ricordo di quali materia però mi
ricordo che ero super inanza super
agitata queste alle 3 del mattino
entrano ubriache fradice e vi dicono
mari stasera conte dormirà lui ma io
dico ma perche io avrei società su major
nereto voi sapete che io domani
all'esame importate gente a casa ma
andate a dormire d'altra parte io voglio
segnare presto niente non mi riguarda
l'esame il giorno dopo ma una cosa è
certa
ci ho litigato perché voglio dire ce la
fate niente cosa è successo una di
queste due amiche poi si è trasferita
all'estero per ne andate in erasmus e
quindi poi è successo che la casa che
sarà stavamo in due è diventata solo mia
perchè l'altra queste fidanzata aspetta
26 fidanzata all'altra andate in erasmus
quindi io sono rimasta da sola e vi
posso assicurare ragazzi che è stato
l'anno più produttivo della mia vita
cioè io all'università comunque andava a
lezione mi impegnavo il primo anno
ovviamente cazzeggiavo un po di più
perché dal liceo ariosità ci sta che un
pochino ti lasci andare che non sei
tutti i giorni da studiarci e dice io il
secondo anno da quando ho iniziato a
vivere da sola ragazzi ero messo in
testa modello io tornavo a casa e gli
appunti della lezione che magari
prendevo velocemente il prendevo a mano
perché io so perché non voglio provare
il computer non è quindi li prendevo
tutti amano gli scrivevo male
tornavo a casa la sera emili me liri
scrivevo bene tutti i perfetti ordinati
vi rendete conto malattie
sta di fatto che sta benissimo
quell'anno e stavo bene cioè vivevo bene
da sola anche se sono persona a cui
piace stare in compagnia c per accetterà
è stato un anno super produttivo e super
positive wives peccato che il terzo anno
per cosa è successo che avevo trovato
una casa molto carina e mi serviva una
conquilina perché spesso succede anche
questo nel senso tu magari trovi la casa
bella che ovviamente ha un pezzo
consistente dici se ci sono due o tre
camere cerco una con culina o2
conquilini quindi rientro di quelle
spese perfetto io avevo trovato questa
casa e scrivo l'annuncio pubblico su
online e scrivo cerco conquilina
eccetera eccetera
mi risponde subito una ragazza straniera
che doveva venire in erasmus e io super
contenta perché comunque mi piace
tantissimo parlare altre lingue
confrontarmi con altre culture eccetera
eccetera quindi rosso per presa bene
arriva questa ragazza e che è
l'apparenza di sem brava simpatica ha
passato un anno di erasmus chiusa in
camera a guardare le serie tv la
televisione eccetera eccetera che per
carità lo faccio anch'io
adesso riguarda fissarle connesse
guardare le sere però voglio dire se in
un altro paese è comunque una conquilina
che era super socievole con te anzi
tantissime volte dicevo vieni andiamo
qui andiamo a ballare vieni con me ed
era sempre un no preferisco servizi non
ho mai capito perché magari aveva dei
problemi come li racconta va però capito
chi fai comunque un'esperienza
all'estero un minimo di scoprire la
città cioè non aveva mai visto il duomo
per farvi capire cielo dovuto trascinare
a forza un anno in una città mai visto
niente io basita
ma questo non era il punto cruciale
il punto fondamentale è che purtroppo
era sporca in che senso sporca dai senso
che
mi dispiace andare nel dettaglio ma io
dovevo dire la sua merda del cesso
vi rendete conto io con lo scovolino
spazzino cioè va bene tutto però no non
esiste io avevo i conati di vomito fare
sta cosa cioè e il problema qual è che
io mi vergognavo per lei ad andarle a
dire guarda che hai sporcato lo so che
avrei dovuto farlo però c'è io al suo
posto sarei diventata fucsia quindi per
evitarle l'imbarazzo
io stavo zitta e infatti poi me ne sono
pentita perché voglio dire non vedo
perché io devo farlo al posto tuo
cisa parente di questa dismissione endo
l'ansia sopra oltre a questo la
signorina mangiava le mie rob e allora
chi mi conosce sa che io se tu mi chiedi
una cosa te la do super volentieri se
non me lo chiedi e di nascosto premi e
mie cose impazzisco impazzisco perché mi
sembra una mancanza di rispetto
quindi io andavo a far la spesa portavo
su da sola le le casse d'acqua mi facevo
lo sbatto né questa si vedeva e mangiava
nelle cose senza chiederlo perché per
che cosa ti costa questa è stata la mia
esperienza universitaria con dei
conquilini sono sicura che tantissimi di
voi mi capiscono hanno vissuto queste
situazioni quello che vi chiedo se viva
e di scrivere qua sotto nei commenti di
raccontarvi un po insomma le vostre
esperienze con i conquilini di farmi
sapere insomma che tipologie di
conquilini avete avuto perché magari
potrei farci un altro video magari le
tipologie di conquilini se non l'avete
ancora fatto mi raccomando iscrivetevi
al canale cliccate sulla campanella per
non perdere
prossimi video e mi raccomando seguitemi
su tutti gli altri social forum facebook
e theo vi mando un bacione ci vediamo al
prossimo video ciao
[Musica]